there is a mental model called inversion
according to inversion when we Face a
daunting problem the best course of
action is to think backwards namely by
going back to the fundamentals of the
issue and trying to deconstruct its main
constituents who end up increasing the
chances of solving it or at least
decreasing the chances of allowing it to
inflict misery Upon Us inversion despite
its very useful nature is an unknown
term for most of us we're kind of
programmed to believe that the best way
to solve a problem is just by
capitalizing on conventional wisdom and
what already works we clink to Safe
patterns that we feel accustomed to and
we repeat these patterns perpetually
without questioning or without the
willingness to test something different
the roots of this Behavior are many for
starters we have the path of least
resistance in physics the path of least
resistance is the physical or
metaphorical pathway that provides the
least resistance to forward motion by by
a given object or entity among a set of
alternative paths in the local language
we use it to allude to the proclivity of
humans to avoid doing the hard things
then we have the Notions of ego and
identity when a person is faced with a
situation that challenges the essence of
their identity that is the substrate of
their belief system the mere thought of
challenging this belief system
destabilizes the backbone of their being
finally we need to deal with the
struggle entailed in many levels of the
societies we have created humans weren't
ready to face the consequences of being
Primal beings in technologically evolved
worlds despite the fact that living
conditions keep improving and wellness
indexes keep Rising psychologically
humans aren't doing well complexity has
infected the fabric of society and
things that seemed simple in the past
now require more effort than before this
makes us feel sad frustrated stressed
and lost as you can imagine it takes a
combination of Courage emotional
resilience and tenacity to be able to
properly navigate within this complex
landscape and the interesting part is
that due to entropy and due to our
proclivity towards growth complexity
increases exponentially there is no way
to avoid that and For Better or For
Worse the best idea is to make peace
with complexity in order to alleviate
the frustration that it causes the word
complexity originates from the word
complex which means composed of
interconnected Parts the reason I use
the etymology of the word complexity is
to allow awareness to grow through
understanding I have always been a huge
proponent of the systems thinking
philosophy and one of my strongest
beliefs has always been that confusion
is a result of a lack of integration of
Parts within thinking systems we become
confused because something is missing or
because something doesn't feel right the
Symphony of interconnected parts that
gives rise to complexity is not in tune
with our awareness and as a result The
Melody of our world becomes distorted
humans don't like Distortion or at least
we are not programmed to like it our
role is to become maestros of our part
of the world and orchestrate the right
Symphony we can't really become maestros
of the whole world because the whole
world is beyond our scope of
understanding and the symphony becomes
too vast when the symphony becomes too
vast it feels like a mismatch of chaotic
elements and we end up floating in a
notion of far-fetched possibilities and
opportunities nobody likes to float
aimlessly nobody likes to feel lost
the somewhat lengthy but necessary
introduction served as a Prelude to the
challenging question what is the meaning
of life this question is so common but
at the same time so potent that I don't
really know how to handle it whenever I
have to face it creating meaning in life
is a very personal process I can't
answer this question for you what I can
say is that the creation of meaning is
affected by complexity and one cannot
create meaning without showcasing a
rather basic understanding of how
complexity affects almost every decision
we have to make the amount of external
stimuli that increases exponentially
through technology and through social
networks affects our pursuit of meaning
when we are interconnected with so many
agents around the world we feel that we
want everything even if we don't really
possess the capacity to imagine what
everything would feel like I guess
that's why everyone enjoys the idea of
parallel universes we want so many
things that only multiple interconnected
versions of ourselves can offer that
large jury in this weird landscape most
of us failed to recognize one Paramount
detail about human nature were quite
valuable creatures meaning that we are
capable of making mistakes or being
wrong and it is this valuability that we
need to reduce in order to make our
experience more tolerable and eventually
come up with a proper meaning for our
lives in the current point in time two
seem to be the most relevant rules we
need to follow in order to reduce
valuability to pick our battles wisely
and to embrace slowness
struggle is a very abstract notion what
exactly constitutes struggle struggle
doesn't commence organically it
manifests itself via interaction and
conflict with entities and systems that
don't share the same interests needs and
beliefs every process you try to put in
place every dream you want to
materialize is susceptible to hurdles
and unpredictable events the world feels
like a huge Battlefield and you need to
be ready not just to fight but to fight
the right battles it is a fundamental
principle of strategic Warfare that each
strategist needs to know their strengths
and weaknesses in order to understand
their capacity to win but winning is not
just related to fighting but also
knowing when to fight and whom to fight
when we embark on Endeavors nowadays
most of the time we do so without
properly evaluating our strategy we ask
the question what is the meaning of life
and we haven't even taken baby steps
towards cultivating more self-aware
awareness and understanding the world
better we want elusive things and keep
fantasizing about them week after week
month after month year after year yet
nothing happens when we create fantasies
about future events in our life that
keep remaining fantasies we start to
lose touch with reality and we just
bolster the delusional aspect of our
world whenever I reach this point I take
a step back and ask myself have you
prepared for the battles that you have
to face before you start chasing the
meaning of life pick your battles and
pick them wisely
how to change the world
my answer
is
by becoming
a subjective part
of the consequences of a local event
becoming a subjective part of the
consequences of local events
at the different level
fall in love
can be change the world
the French philosopher Lynn but you
introduced back in 1988 in his Magnus
Opus being an event the philosophical
notion of the term event according to
Badu an event is an unpredictable break
in our everyday worlds that opens new
possibilities what an event does is that
it serves as a Rapture in being through
which the individual finds realization
and reconciliation with truth in order
however for this Rapture to manifest
itself and have an impact on the
constitution of the individual being
there is not enough the individual needs
to achieve Oneness with the event itself
this philosophy accounts for all sorts
of events but it serves as an allusion
to depth and slowness famous physicists
and philosopher Richard feinman used to
say that everything can become
interesting if you go into it deeply
enough that kind of thinking and way of
life can't emerge organically in the
fast-paced world we have constructed it
is taking a step back and realizing that
the only way to assume control over the
process is that we decide to internalize
is to slow down and take our time even
if the whole world tells us otherwise
through slowness and depth emerges a new
way of being one where the notion of
time and experiences re-engineered
through the prism of meticulous
introspection and observation of our
existence not necessarily one that leads
to over analysis and results in further
paralysis but one way slow thought
creates its own time and place and
hedges the individual from most
calamities that mindless living can
create with slowness and depth one can
be always ready and use whatever tools
are in place at any given time Italians
have a name for this aranjiase it is the
art of improvisation a way of using the
resources at hand to forge Solutions
with such a mindset you no longer need
to ask what is the meaning of life
you're just ready to create training
with whatever life throws at you
[Music]